ladies and gentlemen friends and
colleagues I want to welcome you here
today to the date on the question is the
Strategic Defense Initiative in the
national interest to address this topic
we have with us two men who might be
characterized as the architects of the
president's Strategic Defense Initiative
and two of the program's most formidable
critics each of our participants holds
an impressive set of credentials and
unparalleled advocacy skills there is
little doubt that they will do credit to
their respective points of view this
debate has been organized by space watch
a non-profit research and investigative
organization I want to thank the staff
under Eric first for their capable
organizing effort to bring all of this
together this event could hardly be more
timely three weeks from today President
Reagan President Reagan and general
secretary Gorbachev will be in the midst
of a major summit meeting here in
Washington while the primary purpose of
the summit will be to conclude a
long-awaited treaty to eliminate
intermediate and short-range missiles in
Europe it will also set the stage for
other critical negotiations for the INF
treaty is just the tip of the iceberg of
arms control measures needed to reduce
the enormous strategic nuclear weapons
arsenal of both superpowers whether the
whether the Strategic Defense Initiative
proves to be a bargaining chip or an
impediment to achieving deep reductions
in strategic nuclear weapons remains to
be seen but our hope is that this debate
will provide a provocative value to the
Washington summit moreover I would hope
that our distinguished panelists will
provide insights and some effective
debate
points for those of us who will wrestle
with these difficult questions in the
Congress and equally important to those
who will be running in 1988 for the
presidency of the United States at this
debate we intend to disprove a
pessimistic axiom written by British
critic Cyril Connolly who once said
where there are two alternatives one
intelligent one stupid one noble one
ignoble one serious and sincere one
undignified and one false one farsighted
one short we invariably choose the
latter we have agreed to the following
ground rules for this debate by flip of
the coin we have agreed that the
speaking order will be as follows
it will open with Richard Perle then to
Richard Gowen then to James Abramson and
then to Carl Sagan opening statements
will be limited to five minutes and we
will be strict about adhering to these
time limits in the front row we have a
time of who will signal the chair and
the speakers when the clock is down to
30 seconds for rebuttal
we will reverse the speaking order
allowing no more than four minutes for
each panelist following the rebuttals we
will allow questions between the
panelists in the original order each
panelist will be allowed one question
directed to one or both of the opposing
panelists responses will be no more than
two minutes and finally each speaker
will be given three minutes for their
closing statements and the closing
statements will be presented in reverse
order of the opening statements then it
will be the audience's turn everyone
should have received a card upon
entering the room if you would like to
put a question to one of the panelists
write your question on the card and the
panelists you would like to address it
to and also your name there will be
space launch staff members with nametags
to pick up the cards throughout the
debate I will I will then put the
questions to the panelists we will try
to hold as much time as possible for
your questions without any further delay
let me introduce panelists dr. Carl
Sagan is the David Duncan professor of
astronomy and space sciences and
director of the laboratory for planetary
studies at Cornell University in
addition to more than 600 published
scientific papers and popular articles
dr. Sagan is author co-author or editor
of more than 20 books including comet
contact and the dragons of Eden for
which he was awarded the Pulitzer Prize
his Emmy and Peabody award-winning
television series cosmos became the most
widely watched series in the history of
American Public Television and has now
been seen in 60 countries by over 300
million people the accompanying book
also called cosmos was on the New York
Times bestseller list for seventy weeks
and is the best-selling science book
ever published in the English language
Lieutenant General James a Abramson is
director of the strategic president's
Strategic Defense Initiative
organization he is responsible for
managing and selecting key research and
development programs designed to
eliminate the threat posed by strategic
nuclear ballistic missiles and to
increase the contributions of defensive
systems to u.s. and allied security the
general is a command and test pilot with
more than 3,000 flying hours he has a
Bachelor of Science degree in area
aeronautical engineering from the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and a Master of Science degree in the
same field through the Air Force
Institute of Technology at the
University of Oklahoma in addition
general Abramson holds three honorary
Doctorate degrees in engineering from
New York University from Utah State
University and from Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute the Honorable
Richard Perle from 1981 until May 1987
mr. pearl served as assistant secretary
of defense for international
policy from his office at the Pentagon
he had responsibility for theater and
strategic nuclear weapons policy trade
and technology exports European and
North Atlantic Treaty Organization
policy and negotiations between the
United States and its Western Allies and
the Soviet Union since leaving the
Department of Defense Secretary pearl
has become a resident scholar at the
American Enterprise Institute in
Washington DC and a contributing editor
of US News World Report he has concluded
a contract with Random House for a
political novel that is intended for
publication in 1988 and finally Richard
Gowen was born in Cleveland Ohio and
received a degree in a PhD in physics
from the University of Chicago in 1949
after three years on the faculty of the
University of Chicago he joined IBM
corporation in 1952 and is at present
IBM fellow at the Thomas J Watson Watson
Research Center Yorktown Heights New
York adjunct research fellow at the
Kennedy School of Government Harvard
University Andrew G white professor at
logic arnelle University and adjunct
professor of physics at Columbia
University in addition he is a
consultant to the US government on
matters of military technology and arms
control he has published more than 200
papers and has been granted 34 United
States patents so that is a panel it is
a distinguished one we look forward to a
lively and enlightening debate and we
will begin with an opening statement
from Richard Perle I must say mr.
chairman as I look at the audience I'm
reminded of the story of Machiavelli on
his deathbed
we have a microphone Ian can you hear
a priest was summoned and arrived at the
nut scene of every side he leaned over
and said if you renounce the devil and
embrace the Lord no response repeated
the question the second time without
response in the third part finally after
the third time Machiavelli slowly lifted
his head from the felons and father this
is no time to be making new enemies at
the risk of making enemies I intend to
discuss today the view that the
Strategic Defense Initiative is indeed
in the national interest and I will do
so under five broad categories first the
current situation then what is the
Strategic Defense Initiative something
about the Soviet program something about
defensive systems conceptually and
finally some remarks about the future of
technology the current situation is easy
to describe as of today the United
States is wholly incapable of stopping
the ballistic missile fired at our
territory even a single ballistic
missile even a missile fired by accident
even a single missile fired by let's say
an errant Soviet submarine commander no
capability
what celebrity we would have to watch it
complete its trajectory and reach its
target this is unprecedented in human
history that a threat as obviously large
as the threat of a nuclear weapon
striking our territory is to go without
any response whatsoever it represents
unprecedented indifference to the need
to provide even minimal insurance
against the possibility of an accident
or a miscalculation for those who
believe that the most probable nuclear
war is a nuclear war
launched and initiated as part of a plan
to achieve political purposes or for
those who believe that an accident could
take place it seems to me
basic common sense to deal with both
contingencies including what I happen to
believe is more likely which is the
possibility overtime of an accident now
what is the Strategic Defense Initiative
as a response to the situation it is
first of all a research and development
program no decision has been made to
deploy the fruits of that research and
development program nor could one
intelligently be made before the
research and development and testing and
evaluation is complete the program is
aimed at determining whether we have the
technological and financial resources to
develop and perhaps eventually deploy a
defense that would strengthen our
national security and give us reasonable
insurance against the possibility of an
accident but we can't answer that
question until the research development
testing and evaluation are complete and
I find it surprising that men of science
without waiting for the answers without
waiting for the research to go forward
have made up their minds a strategic
defense that might result from the
program of research and development that
we have end-of-life need not in my
judgment be a perfect defense although
there are those who believe it must a
partial defense would protect us against
an accident or miscalculation a partial
defense would strengthen deterrence by
protecting the critical elements of our
own determent posture the Soviets have a
Strategic Defense Initiative they don't
advertise it but they've been hard at
work developing technologies very much
along the lines of those that we have
underway and indeed they invest mess
differences conceptually we do a great
deal of a defensive nature we put
concrete around our missiles so that
they can't be destroyed or we make the
mobile or we hide them under the oceans
and submarines
I see no fundamental difference in
concept between the sort of passive
defenses that we all recognize as vital
to maintaining an adequate deterrent and
the active defenses that could serve as
a last resort is a device capable of
intercepting ballistic missiles when all
other passive defenses and when the
nature of the US deterrent has failed if
it does to deter or if an accident takes
place finally let me say that I find it
difficult to believe that we can stop
the march of technology now and forever
almost arrogance to believe that the
Soviets are at work and will continue
their program we couldn't verify
termination of their program if they
claimed to do so and to believe that in
the year 2050 let's say we will be where
we are today with respect to defensive
technology is to ignore the lessons of
history so the issue before us is
whether we will be part of the effort to
develop this technology and explore our
options or whether we will drop out at
this effort and leave it to others to
make their decision in their
determination and perhaps to emerge with
a monopoly of strategic defense
capability thank you our next panelist
dr. Richard Gowen for an opening
statement but let us return to the
origins of the SDI in the March 1983
speech by President Reagan where he
noted that deterrence of nuclear war has
worked and will continue to work but
that it is morally preferable to rely on
defense we need however a defense so
good that we can threaten no one then we
can give up our own nuclear weapons and
it won't matter whether the Soviets
retain theirs if they use them against
us they'll do us no harm
they will rust they will become impotent
and obsolete
four days later Secretary of Defense
Caspar Weinberger said that we were
seeking not any kind of partial defense
but a total total and reliable defense
and he saw no reason why we couldn't
achieve it four years later this
February in his testimony secretary
Weinberger said that the administration
seeks a completely effective system that
will be a thoroughly reliable defense
and will be able to destroy Soviet
missiles as they come out of their silos
and if any should be missed then at the
separation phase and so on we would
destroy them we would protect entire
continents it would not be designed to
protect missile sites or anything of
that kind but would protect populations
well those are great hopes and great
promises and that's how the FBI began
but that president is ill served by the
pretense that has deceived secretary
Weinberger that permit him to believe
that the president's goal is still the
goal and the promise of the SDI indeed
that goal is now stated by the SDIO
organization as enhancing deterrence of
nuclear war whereas the president's aim
was explicitly to replace deterrence the
president's goal was to be able to give
up persuasion of the Soviet leaders not
to attack us or our allies instead
rendering a nuclear attack carmly-- last
year in a debate with me in Baltimore
general Abrams and special assistant
defined quantitatively what SDI must
accomplish for its leaders to believe
that they have successfully carried out
their mission and deterred nuclear war
he said the Soviets could right now
destroy 6,000 military targets in the
United States with their strategic
nuclear weapons he said that if SDIO
could show us the way to limiting the
Soviet targets destroyed in the United
States to 3,000 then the Soviets would
be deterred not accomplishing their
military goals they would never attack
but what about defense of population
that we've heard about now that was the
president's goal would we defend our
cities no he said there's no military
benefit to the Soviets in destroying US
or allied cities so they would not
strike them and we would not need to
defend our population according to FBI
oh the Russian bear has become the
Soviet pussycat apparently SDIO says we
are to forget about preventing soviet
composer coercion of us or its allies
we're supposed to forget about the
threat the secretary pearl has been
stressing for the last 15 years by that
logic nuclear war could be reliably
prevented and freedom preserved by our
unilaterally giving up our entire
military we would have no more military
targets to be destroyed
therefore no threat of war more
realistically there is now the very real
prospect of deep cuts in the Soviet
nuclear weapon force beginning with
1,500 warheads to be eliminated in the
INF treaty to be signed in three weeks
here in Washington and they cut a 50% or
more in strategic nuclear weapons this
is a surer way and a quicker way to
preserve those military targets in the
United States than by continuing with
the research program which is bound to
fail now am i against the Strategic
Defense absolutely not
I think the unprecedented indifference
that you heard about from Secretary
pearl ignoring the threat of the
missiles fired by accident of a single
missile fired by an errant Soviet
commander ignoring the threat to the
Minuteman is caused by the fact that the
leaders of the United States have not
had presented to them limited programs
to accomplish these limited options soon
and economically over the decades I've
been much involved in this sort of thing
and have proposed for instance both in
defense of the Minuteman silos taking
advantage of the fact that a Minuteman
silo
survive if you can keep the nuclear
warheads more than a couple hundred
yards away no interest in this
government or in previous
administrations because we do not regard
the threat to Minutemen as real in 1983
President Reagan's Scowcroft Commission
on strategic forces said that Minuteman
vulnerability could well occur but that
the overall force would be invulnerable
and deterrence assured because of the
presence of the submarines and the
aircraft as for the accidental launch of
any number of Soviet missiles we can
solve that problem in a year and I've
written about it for many years by
retaining on the Soviet missiles in
operation as well as on our own missiles
the command destruct link that you saw
work so well on the two solid rocket
boosters in the Challenger accident the
same is true against terrorist launch of
single ICBMs we have a weapon already in
place it's called the CIA if we need a
backup it can be the Minuteman - to
perform a nuclear intercept thousands of
kilometers away thank you thank you
doctor our next panelist once again
Lieutenant General James Abramson
throughout this debate what you often
hear are my judgment over simplistic
arguments on a very very complex subject
so I must start with a description of
what the program truly is and build on
what Richard Perle has outlined and
secondly reject what I consider to have
been the simplistic argument and in fact
dr. Garwin is often defining for me what
my objective is the objective is very
clear the objective was laid out in the
president's program and has not modified
it was a three-fold challenge that the
president laid out the first one was
isn't there a strategy that might be
more effective for all the unknowns or
the future
and that strategy is one a search for a
strategy that would not keep the nation
naked to the worst weapon that's ever
been developed in history secondly that
a strategy by itself is insufficient in
fact to prevent war in fact the strategy
must be supported by true technical
development so it can be implemented and
finally a very important element right
from the start was to use our
development use our technical prowess to
enhance the ability to achieve
meaningful arms reductions in the
process and it is the combination of all
three of these elements that truly is
the Strategic Defense Initiative it is
not merely an attempt to build a Blazers
or to go to war in space now the
technique that is often used is in fact
to depuis debunk this concept is to
reach way out into the future and to
take three basic kinds of things the
first one is to define a poor system one
that we can't afford the Union of
Concerned Scientists have often done
that and if you go through their various
reports from the first one in March of
1984 where they define what it is we're
trying to build and said that for a
particular kind of laser would probably
take something like 2,400 battle
stations and then costed that and over
time have finally come to the point that
for those same conditions that in fact
it is not 2,400 but is on the order of
as dr. Darwin indicated in his nature
article 46 to 50 then he shifted years
changed the fundamental problem and went
back to the 2000 and by the way dick and
when I was in school it really wasn't
effective to when I got the answer wrong
to change the problem I usually didn't
get any credit for that
the same kind of reasoning has occurred
in several other places but let me move
on in some cases they make a simple
analysis which is either irrelevant or
wrong and use that in the arguments to
say that it cannot be achieved and again
the Union of Concerned Scientists and
laying out their discussion on the
neutral particle beam scientifically
made the dramatic error that made this
in fact an impossible achievement and in
fact is incorrect finally they say that
it can't survive very often and one of
the ways in which they approach this is
that they do a theoretical analysis and
which is practically and operationally
not significant now all of those are
arguments that are often used but
frankly those are details the
fundamental principles that each of you
should consider is do we for ever wish
to rely only on a vision that is
dominated by a single weapon and that
weapon being and having our country and
perhaps their country laid open to that
weapon now the single most important
characteristic of any deterrent strategy
and by the way very often and in fact in
my last debate with you Paul there was a
final assertion that what we're dealing
with here is destabilizing what we must
do is look to the single most important
characteristic of any deterrence
strategy and that is does it when the
crisis develops when the problems
developed when the misunderstandings
develop does it discourage a first
strike with these in powerful powerful
weapons or does it discourage it so I
would like to leave a challenge in fact
two challenges with the other members of
this panel and they are to explain how
it is that defenses truly are disable
and secondly to explain how it is that
they will deal with the fact that the
Soviet had such an aggressive program
searching in each of these fundamental
areas because remember the Soviets have
been invaded
they understand just how it is
that a nation cannot survive
particularly under surprise attack they
learned that in 1942 and in the first
world war so if you would please explain
what your proposal is to deal with and
there are many of these over on the side
what the Soviet challenge is in
strategic defense and for those of you I
won't go into all of the details of that
for those of you who would like to see
it there are some booklets on the side
that explain it Thank You general
and our final opening statement will be
presented by dr. Kyle fake Thank You
congressman Markey there are almost
60,000 nuclear weapons in the world
nearly 25,000 of them so-called
strategic weapons which are designed to
go from the homeland of one nation to
the homeland of another there are only
2300 cities on the planet Earth if you
define a city as having a hundred
thousand people or more and this is one
of many ways of indicating the grotesque
disproportionality between the power of
the nuclear arsenals of the United
States in the Soviet Union and any
conceivable use it is very likely that
in case of a so-called central exchange
between the United States and the Soviet
Union the long-run ultimate deaths will
be several billion people and given
these stark and unprecedented barrels it
is natural to try to find a way out
this trap that the United States and the
Soviet Union have set for themselves and
the rest of the planet jury-rigging
booby trapping the planet Earth with
60,000 weapons of unprecedented ferocity
and destructive power the idea therefore
of defending against a massive attack by
the potential adversary is attractive
and was reflected in the president's
March 23rd 1983 speech in which he
explicitly thought about population
defense not to enhance deterrence not
improving the balance of terror not
shooting down an errant missile or one
launched by a-- by a terrorist group or
a rogue nation but defense of the
continent to the United States and this
has clearly been the intent of the
president and the recently retired
Secretary of Defense but because this is
so difficult to manage there is a
temptation to shift the ground to invent
more modest objectives and that is why
we now hear of these other objectives
and this is sufficiently serious that it
has been called on the floor of the
Senate a bait and switch
factor the population is drawn in by the
prospect of being defended even against
a massive Soviet attack and when they're
in the used car salon then they are
offered something more modest and the
hope is that known you will notice SDI
is fine if it is perfect that is if no
significant number of Soviet warheads
leaks through the shield the most
optimistic numbers you can hear from
technically competent advocates of Star
Wars is 70 80 or maybe even 90 percent
of income
Soviet warheads destroyed well take the
more optimistic number if 90% are
destroyed 10% get through and percent of
say 10,000 Soviet warheads is 1000
warheads 1,000 warheads is much more
than is needed to obliterate the United
States the shield is leaky now this is
different from the usual presentation
say on network television where what you
see is a two or three warheads on lazy
arcing trajectories each of which has
the letters CCCP on them so we know
whose they are
and then screen left comes a spiffy
laser battle station with letters USA on
it so they know which one that is and
then there is a noise like three flashes
of light and surgically removed from the
screen are the three Soviet warheads and
that's that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the video arcade version of SDI
and it has dominated the thinking of
most Americans on this issue an actual
representation which we've made an
attempt in this painting by John
Lumbergh to the right to demonstrate is
an over a text us SDI system shooting
down some fraction of the incoming
warheads with hundreds or thousands of
warheads penetrating the defense landing
on u.s. territory and that's what all
those little orange mushroom clouds are
that you don't see on network television
representations of solace there is a
delusion of perfection if you look at
the weapon systems that have been
procured during this administration and
look at the immense numbers of
embarrassing failures if you look at the
241 deaths of the Marines in Lebanon or
the 37 deaths on the USS start if you
look at the Shuttle disaster or if you
like Chernobyl it becomes very clear
that the enormous reliability required
for Star Wars will be the same
contractors responsible for all those
other systems responsible for star wars
is simply not achievable and that is its
most serious defect it has many defects
but that's its most serious one
that concludes the period for our
opening statements we now move to the
rebuttal period and the speakers will be
recognized in reverse order and so for a
four minute time period now we will
recognize those speakers and we will
begin with dr. Carl Sagan
if it were today we will leave it to
read decision of the various teams and
their choices to have dr. Godwin begin
on the rebuttal period we will recognize
dr. garland for four minutes
thank you let's bring us back to a
discussion of the SDI program human
which general Abramson has been in
charge of spending some five billion
dollars and for which the Fletcher
Committee in 1983 which wrote the
technical blueprint for the research
program said that sudden some seventy
billion dollars would be required
seventy billion dollars over about ten
years so that's what we're discussing
and the things that are being said now
not what people may or may not have said
before I want to address a couple of the
questions that have been raised for
instance in December 1986 the former
head of system design studies for the
FBI Oh joined with four colleagues to
publish a proposal for early deployment
of an FBI defense incidentally it had
2000 defensive satellites whatever
different types from those that general
Abramson was talking about but two years
ago President Reagan signed a national
security decision directive number 172
which said that no SDI system could be
considered for deployment unless it was
adequately survivable and cheaper to
build than to overcome by more offense
why is that well this addresses the
question that general Abramson asked how
our defense is destabilizing because the
State Department published a an official
explanation of this NSB d17 to it said
that if it was not at if he's adequately
survivable it would provoke attack on
the system provoke nuclear war rather
than prevent it and if it were cheaper
to build them to overcome with more
offensive weapons it would stimulate a
nuclear arms race in offensive weapons
rather than quench one I see however the
same kind of head in the sand
ostrich behavior toward this question of
survivability and cotton that has led to
the Challenger disaster and to a number
of other failures especially
director presence it is worse this time
because we are not up against nature
cold launch weather we're not up against
the engineering realities of a
supersonic transport airplane we are up
against the cleverness and determination
and resources of the Soviet Union which
if they wanted to have their weapons
negated could just throw them away
so obviously it's worth a great deal to
them as it is to us to maintain the
effectiveness of our nuclear weapons let
me address another question as to why
the Soviets have such a large program in
defense and in every one of these areas
discussed in the SDI first they don't
the defense literature itself says that
there is no evidence that the Soviets
although they work in neutral particle
beams for fusion research and so on no
evidence that they have a weapon program
in neutral particle beams they do not
have the space-based ABM experiments
thus far that we are proposing they have
had in the distant past and he satellite
test as we have had and they have a
deployed system for defense against
ballistic missiles in the Moscow area
there one site permitted under the 1972
ABM Treaty just as we had a better
system operated for the year 1975 76 in
Grand Forks North Dakota the key to the
question though of destabilization is in
the other part of general Abramson's
request the Soviets know the perils of a
surprise attack and that's exactly why
they fear a u.s. FBI that is exactly why
Caspar Weinberger said that the a Soviet
SDI program would be the worst strategic
nightmare he could imagine because a
system incapable of defending against a
first strike might be very good at
defending against a retaliatory strike
the little that left after the other
side has been
organized
next week we turn in rebuttal - Richard
/ well Thank You mr. chairman
dick Darwin believes that arms control
is a superior way to diminish the threat
that we face the deck arms control and
SDI are not necessarily mutually
exclusive I can recall not long ago when
the Soviet said there would be no
agreement on intermediate forces unless
we abandon STR and we in all likelihood
will sign precisely such an agreement
when the summit takes place in Norfolk
moreover our proposals to reduce
offensive forces met with the Strategic
Defense Initiative I'm glad to see that
dr. Garwin believes in limited defenses
so do I but I'm touched by professor
Darwin's confidence and the CIA's
ability to deal with all contingencies
it's a knot of confidence that I share
and I see no reason why we shouldn't
have the insurance that would go with
knowing and if a missile should be
launched at us we would have some
capability some chance of preventing it
from during the destruction that would
otherwise do dr. Garwin says that the
SDI program is bound to fail what is it
that's bound to fail all research and
development in this area even the
development of limited defenses of
partial defense even a defense that
might strengthen deterrence by depriving
the Soviets and confidence that they
could launch an attack against us and
have enough of their weapons reach their
targets to diminish unacceptably our
capacity to respond and how do we know
it'll fail history is littered with the
intellectual debris of people who
believe that things could not be done
for men of science I find this certainty
not skepticism but certainty that our
research and Technology effort must fail
truly astounding after growing believes
that there's no evidence that the
Soviets have an SDI program
that I can assure you that the Soviets
are investing heavily in a broad array
of technologies all aimed at determining
what kind of strategic defenses might be
deployed and the evidence on this is
overwhelming now some of you may have
noticed that in his remarks Carl Sagan
refused seriously to respond to the
notion that there are objectives and
purposes in the SDI program other than
the construction of the perfect defense
he much prefers to erect as a straw man
the concept of a perfect defense and
then attack them I don't believe that
one needs assume a perfect defense in
order seriously to face the questions if
should we be without any defense is
there not something in between
perfection and absolutely nothing that
makes sense that's in our national
security interest that might protect
lines if a disaster should happen the
accuse is the proponents of SDI of
having switched objectives as though a
program could have only one objective
and the most demanding objective most
military programs have multiple
objectives and that's as true of the SDI
program as it is of many evidence and
one of those objectives is to strengthen
deterrence by diminishing the Soviet
capacity to execute an effective attack
and another one a vital one in my view
is to deal with precisely the kind of
accident that dr. Sagan referred to in
another context he reminded us of
Chernobyl he reminded us of the
Challenger accident and yet he would sit
here and deny us even a research and
development program knowing that
accidents can happen and I regret to say
that over the long run accidents
undoubtedly will happen there is indeed
a video arcade vision of SDI but it is
Carl Sagan's not that of the program
managers the program is exploring a
broad array of technologies we don't
know whether it can be done we're
withholding judgments about whether it
should be done but we'll never know
until we try and
we reduce a broad and serious program to
Lange cartoon and I can understand how
one would be discouraged from proceeding
forward if that isn't the program that
we've embarked upon and I think we all
have to answer the question of whether
we are prepared so err early so breezily
you take the risks of having no program
whatsoever with whatever consequences
that may entail thank you next in
rebuttal dr. Carl Sagan thank you I
think we're seeing an important shift in
the opinions of those outside of the
White House who are supporting SDI note
the concentration in general Abramson
and mr. Quarles discussion on enhancing
deterrence it is as if they have
acknowledged that defending the civilian
population is impossible it's an
admission of the failure of the
president's vision and if there is a
cartoon representation of SDI it is
Ronald Reagan's representation and I
think if they wish to distance
themselves from the president's vision
they should do so explicitly on the
issue of other ways of enhancing
deterrence
that's no problem at all but is SDI the
most effective the most reliable way of
enhancing deterrence and we can argue
that there are many other ways to do
that mobile land-based missiles are de
Merville submarine fleet ballistic
missile submarines are and other new
technologies by no means clear than
anything like SDI is the best way to
enhance the terms as for research and
development of course there should be
research and development but nothing
like the three to four billion dollar
costs that we have today I'd like to say
something about
naturally the advocates of SDI do not
wish to put a dollar tag on what a
full-up system will cost secretaries of
defense former secretaries of defense of
both political persuasions have made
estimates in the one to three trillion
dollar range which gives us some idea of
what we are talking about general
Abramson in one of our past debates has
stated that if it was anything like one
trillion dollars he would recommend to
the president not to go ahead and that
is a very important and straightforward
statement from him the kinds of
expenditures were talking about in the
present fiscal climate is a prescription
for economic ruin the United States in
the last six years has gone from the
largest creditor to the largest debtor
nation in the world the present national
debt is not only larger than that of any
previous administration it is larger
than the sum total of all previous
administrations back to that of George
Washington the United States has spent
each year an increment in the defense
department budget during the Reagan
administration which just equals the
increment in the national debt each year
it is not very difficult to see if
there's some connection between the two
as a result of these sorts of
expenditures a rhetoric opposing fiscal
irresponsibility a reality embracing it
the United States is now in many
respects something like an
underdeveloped nation we're 17 from the
world in infant mortality 1/4 of the
population is functionally illiterate
patent applications are steeply down
it'd be much more steeply down it's not
for Richard Darwin there are there are
homeless in the streets of every major
city 20 million people go hungry every
day there are half as many degrees
advanced degrees in science and
technology granted in the United States
each year then there are in Japan
half our population the United States is
14% of the population with safe water
and on and on and on the question is
whether national security is merely
developing more gadgets and I'd like to
just close with a one sentence quote
from Dwight Eisenhower the problem in
defense spending is to figure out how
far you should go without destroying
from within what you are trying to
defend from without and
[Music]
finally in rebuttal General James Davis
dr. Singh and I thought that that was a
very interesting outline of many
problems although I thought this was a
that this nation and other nations have
but I thought that this was a debate
about strategic defence and talking
about baiting and switching I haven't
got the foggiest idea in terms of what
the relationship is between education
and payment and SDI now that's that's
the real issue here and in order to deal
with the real issue and the investment
it's important to understand what we are
spending on the research program the
research program consumes over the last
three years less than 1% of the
Department of Defense budget it consumes
and they average over the last three
years less than one-quarter of 1% of the
total federal budget so if the
implication call is that by eliminating
SDI you are going to solve all those
problems your brilliant problem solver
and I hope very much that you would be
elected to a position of responsibility
to do that
I think there's one more key element
that out must be outline notice the
difference as one when we say that we
are attempting to enhance deterrence
nobody has explained why defenses cannot
enhance deterrence because after all the
first objective is to prevent that
nuclear war in the very first place and
the the contention that we have moved
away from the president's vision is dr.
Sagan and dr. Darwin telling me what I'm
doing I know what I'm doing I know what
the president wants me to do I have my
direction and it's very very clear and
in the first direction that came out it
said that SDI will enhance deterrence
because after all it is intended as a
first objective to prevent war and I
think that it's very important to
illustrate that merely because we
recognize that there is nothing perfect
in this entire world that does not mean
that we do not support the president's
objective of working to make a very
thoroughly reliable or an effective
defense possible now let me deal with
one more key element of this and it's
important to recognize the differences
between even though they may be
stylistically very great the differences
between what we're saying here are not
so great as one might say in both cases
we are saying there should be a research
program in both cases that research
program should be aimed at defense in
the case of dr. Garland he has said it
should be concentrating on terminal
defense the the attempt to defend weapon
in order to enhance deterrence and in
fact he has offered several ideas in
those something called swarm did he's
also offered a unique idea and that's
burying bombs across the northern
territory of the country and blowing it
up in such a way that the dust will stop
the warheads on the way in that's the
last ditch
and I must say as we one looks at it the
real difference here is the thrust of
the program and one more time I would
say we are searching in searching for
the most efficient way to do two things
prevent war by interfering with their
strategy and if the tragedy would ever
occur to find a way to protect as many
human beings on this planet as we could
as we as the creativity of our engineers
and as the resources that the Congress
allows us and not only now but in the
future that can be applied to the
overall program and we are dedicated to
making it affordable and cost-effective
at the margin those criteria and the
really good news is that we are making
progress in all of these fronts we are
making progress in the strategy the
technical progress is immense at this
point and I invite many of you to come
and look at that spend as much time as
you do listening to both sides of the
debate seeing what the real progress is
we have the most open program in history
and thirdly the last challenge the
president laid out was one where for the
first time in history we have the
prospect of true arms reductions in
spite of all of the worrisome efforts
that the critics of the program have
said that this will make it impossible
for the first time we have the real
reduction and we have real negotiable
proposals on the table now that sounds
to me like a successful strategy and a
good news Thank You general very much
now that concludes the opening statement
and rebuttal period we're now going to
move to a period of questions wherein
the panelists can ask one another
questions the the limitation will be
this that collectively each sigh will be
given two minutes
to be decided upon by that side as to
how they will use it in order to respond
to any of the questions which are posed
we would ask that in anticipation of
that that all of you out there who have
been given cards to write your own
questions that you begin to pass them
down to the center of each one of the
aisles and the staff will come down and
pick up your questions so that they can
also be posed to the panelist so let us
begin at this time with a question by
Richard Perle - - a doctor Gowan and dr.
Sagan Karl for how long do you think it
is prudent safe and wise for us to go on
without any capacity whatever to
interfere with even a single
accidentally launched missile and
recognizing as you did that we should
have an SDI program but not at the three
to four billion dollar level what level
do you think is appropriate and how
would you organize that program well
first of all I think we have heard CIA
aside from Richard Garland ways to do it
which don't involve SDI for example the
the fusing by radio signals of warheads
on US and Soviet strategic missiles so
that there is an errant launch they can
be destroyed in flight assuming the
goodwill of our the soil and the use of
existing well if they're really not good
well it's unlikely they would just fire
one
one ballistic missile and the other
method that you mentioned was the use of
Minuteman boosters and warheads to
destroy missile is not so fused the
union or by some other nation or the
idea of a terrorist group having a
ballistic missile is slightly laughable
SDI does not respond to the most likely
delivery mechanisms of terrorist groups
or small nations which are nuclear
weapons in embassy basements in
Washington and motorboats in harbors as
far as what a prudent level of SDI
funding goes I would think something
around a billion dollars a year might
not be excessive next question posed by
dr. Darwin to general Abelson and
Richard Perle general Abramson in a
September 21 report from the department
defense to the Congress it says because
it cannot be expected that the Soviet
threat will remain static a defense that
could be effective if deployed in the
mid-1990s may not be effective if
deployed significantly later
consequently such delays could result in
the loss of deployment options I gather
then that there is a race imagined
between the deployment of a Strategic
Defense and the evolution of the Soviet
strategic threat now your chief
scientist told us last year that FDI
would be feasible only if it could be
done in a totally revolutionary
management fashion taking half the time
of a normal program and you yourself I
believe have said that the launch cost
to orbit has to be reduced from your
$1,500 per pound for the space shuttle
by a fact or factor 10 or so you would
be working with exactly the same
contractors as on the space shuttle and
other defense programs some of which dr.
Sagan mentioned how will you and they
achieve a tenfold reduction in launch
costs below what you were able to do
when you were in charge
the shuttle program and do that
responsibly and predictably sooner than
the Soviets can react how can you assure
the nation and our allies that can be
done dick I'm delighted you asked that
kind of a question and I'm afraid I'll
have to enter since you are arguing by
analogy with my personal history I was
responsible for the maverick missile in
the early days that was when I was in
charge of at the lowest cost and most
effective missile within its
specifications that had ever been
produced the lowest cost most effective
fighter that the United States has
produced is the f-16 and in fact I
brought that in line in three years and
only I didn't do it alone I was
fortunate enough to have a national team
of exactly those contractors that you
are degrading and I would say that when
you compare with the Space Shuttle first
of all when I was in charge of it it was
a safe program secondly it was very
clear from the start that the Space
Shuttle was and a generation of
technology that it would not offer the
cost-effectiveness that we would need
for not only this system for in the
future but others therefore we are
embarked on precisely that and that's
the good news of the program and I can
give you example after example of that
the research is not scientific research
primarily of the kind that is often
suggested creating a new laser or
something of that although part of it is
that let me give you one example of a
good news story of exactly that kind in
every one of these missiles or in every
one of our systems we would have to have
a inertial unit something that tells the
missile where it's pointed and how its
pointed and we have now achieved what I
consider to be an economic breakthrough
in that area where the past all of these
units will cost on the order of a
hundred thousand dollars and we now have
one that will promise in production to
be on the order of five thousand dollars
now I can give you any number of those
but that's part of the good news story
the answer is we will find a way or we
will not propose that it's ready now
we'll stay with the general Abramson as
he poses a question to dr. Darwin and
Sagan I think that it's it's I've
already asked the key question and dr.
Garwin countered by talking about a type
of stability that I think is often
confused there are several types of
stability one is called arms-race
stability and that's what's often used
in these discussions perhaps the most
important one and the one the
characteristic of any of these that I
talked about is this crisis stability
the one where we have a situation not
where it's merely an accidental launch
or maybe it is in fact this this this
terrorist operation but where the real
issue is how do you take away the
incentive to strike now you have given
us a up and and you have not answered my
fundamental question could you describe
how it is that relying exclusively on
offensive missiles forever with all the
technical and political unknowns in the
future truly can offer us the level of
crisis stability the world deserves
that's your question
we really can't rely on offensive
missiles all always we will have some
defense if it is necessary but the
defense for these limited jobs has to be
put up against other means of
accomplishing the same goals and that
was the recommendation of the Scowcroft
commission no defense in our future but
single warhead ICBMs in survivable
basing
either in silos or mobile smaller
submarines to permit the reduction of
nuclear weapons without having all our
eggs in a single submarine basket the
problem is that we want to escape from
the fact of vulnerability and one escape
is into fantasy we know people like that
but that is not an option for a
democracy which wants to take care of
itself and even contribute to the
well-being of the rest of the world so
that's why I propose that we have a
billion dollar-a-year nan SDI program
the SDI is too much advertising too much
demonstration and not enough performance
and it should be oriented to
investigating whether there are any new
ideas out there the ideas that have been
proposed thus far have been found
wanting if you say maybe somebody will
think of something new maybe and we want
to be the first to do so but will not
think of it in a seventy billion dollar
program oriented toward deciding whether
their deployment is possible or not
finally dr. Carl Sagan for all if
general Ableton and mr. pearl thank you
the I want to see if I can succeed in
Durham the distinction of them pushing
out a little bit the President on more
than two dozen occasions has stressed
that SDI is either a four population
defense or B is non nuclear now it's
true that he proposed SDI without much
significant discussion with his advisors
when Secretary of Defense Weinberger
heard about it his comment was it's not
a bomb is it what I would like to ask is
is it true what the president says that
it's for population defense and it's not
nuclear or
is that what SDI is working on or is the
president misinformed
well again Karl you're opposing this is
a choice between alternatives when in
fact it is entirely possible in the SDI
program is indeed intended to explore a
variety of approaches and a variety of
objectives my own judgment you asked the
question earlier if we wish to put
distance between ourselves and the
president why not say so explicitly my
own view is that the president's long
term vision of a comprehensive defense
is just that a long term vision in the
practical world of the near future I
think we're unlikely to accomplish that
but you go to the extreme view would
saying that because you cannot
accomplish a perfect defense in the long
term future you should have no defense
now and that strikes me as dangerous and
then law it's now the program aims at a
layered defense with varying degrees of
capability undoubtedly evolving over
time I believe that from the earliest
deployment of the Strategic Defense we
would have the enormous benefit of
knowing that we had some significant
capability to deal with the kind of
accident that you made a persuasive case
is likely to occur Dick Garwin wants to
do it with Minuteman 2 missiles I can
remember talking to dick Garland 15
years ago about the effectiveness of the
program of ballistic missile defense
that was tailored specifically for that
purpose and his view was as pessimistic
then as his view is today and yet he
thinks you can take an ICBM and over
easily convert it into a an
anti-ballistic missile device if he
would apply that standard of assurance
and confidence to the SDI program he
might trade places with general Abramson
but the fact is that the multi-layered
approach offers every opportunity to
produce some early defenses that are
partially effective and depending on the
evolution of technology it may be
possible someday to reach that more
comprehensive though
but you do not have to accept and I
think would be foolish to accept that
only a comprehensive defense is worth
pursuing and if it can't be pursued then
we should have no defense at all and
that's the essence of your position I
think I do need to add a comment it has
continually posed that a partial defense
or a defense that is building by phases
one step at a time toward the
president's long-term goal is either to
defend strategic weapons or people and
that is not the case if it were exactly
the kind of terminal defense and limited
to the terminal defense as dr. Garwin
has indicated that might be the case
then we would have to make a choice do
we put those terminal defenders around a
city or do we put them around a
Minuteman field that's precisely the
function of a layered defense to ensure
that we can attack the ballistic
missiles at the most efficient area and
that's when they're just getting started
and layers behind that and what we
defend depends on what the Soviets are
shooting at and we will indeed be
defending people we will be defending
people right from the start
it won't be a perfect defense but in the
long run we will continue in a
responsible way and the responsible way
to build anything as radical as this is
a step at a time to get experience in
that first step and then build toward a
second step in enhancing the technology
at each step of the way let us just
conclude at that point on the question
period and move on to questions from the
audience and and we'll begin with a
question which is posed to the Abramson
Perl side we will give them two minutes
to answer and then two minutes to the
other side to also comment upon of what
they've heard the quite the first
question is this since the Soviets are
and are likely to remain adver
Cerys why isn't SDI likely to provoke
the Soviets to deploy additional
offensive weapons in order to offset US
defensive deployments and to enhance
their own deterrent forces general
Abelson mr. pearl two minutes if we were
limited and limited our thinking to
terminal defenses of the kind of dr.
Darwin is talking about that would be
exactly the case a single layer with a
single countable number of responsive
missiles all they have to do is to try
to add a few missiles in order to change
that that's very different than a
layered defense for example five layers
with only 60% effectiveness at each
layer and by the way this is an example
that's all it is but we have very real
possibilities of building to that level
at this point it's quite clear that it's
possible instead of just one or two or
three additional missiles we're talking
about 293 it's impossible for them
within their economic constraints to
deal with a layered defense by doing
precisely that therefore they would
there are logical people on the other
side they're logical adversaries and
they would pick the the approach that
wouldn't break the bank or if I might
add to that the question accepts
implicitly the notion that the Soviets
insist on having offenses at the level
that they now have them and if they
would not be content with any lower
level of offensive capability and yet as
we look at the Soviet offensive force
thousands of warheads on ballistic
missiles in particular many of us
believe that that force is vastly larger
than the Soviets need for deterrence and
if that is the case and by the way the
Soviets themselves had said that they
would be prepared to reduce their forces
if in fact the existing Soviet offense
is excessive to their needs
over and above what is required for
deterrence and they would need not
respond to the degree to which all that
we were taking away from them was that
additional and quite menacing capability
that I believe they're not entitled to
have Arctic Darwin and Sagan two minutes
rebuttal
it is not I who say that defenses are
destabilizing it is the Reagan
administration and explaining the
president's action and I'll just say it
again unless the defense is addict be
survivable it's likely to start a war
rather than prevent a war and unless it
is cheaper to build than to overcome it
will cause an offensive arms race now if
you don't accept those statements
secretary pearl general Abramson argue
with President Reagan the Defense
Department and the State Department now
what you appear to be saying is that
you're confident that you can satisfy
those requirements I see no sign of that
I see inside the SDI a willingness to
assume away the threat to make a
strawman response to fire all the Soviet
nuclear-armed interceptors
simultaneously because that least
effective rather than holding them when
the target or when the targets are
within range
I see a continuing misconception that
space mines have to be covert to be
effective ignoring the fact that they've
always been proposed as over it so once
you find out that there's a space miner
says I am a Soviet space mine
there's been no proposal what to do
about it it's no sense saying we'll find
out it's a Soviet space mine so I
believe that ignoring the requirement
assuming it away is the way to disaster
and that's why I think that the research
in ballistic missile defense ought to be
done without an SDI organization
let me just add going back to what the
question asks it is certainly clear that
if the Soviets wish to maintain a high
probability of a certain fixed level of
damage on
United States and if they believe that a
deployed SDI will be able to shoot down
a certain number of their warheads then
the option open to them are several
options one is to increase the number of
warheads until it compensates for the
capability they imagine for the u.s. SDI
and since it is very likely that the
capability to do that involves existing
technology and will be much cheaper than
SDI we give the Soviets their the
advantage in that issue in addition the
Soviets have opportunities to under fly
SDI if even if SDI were to work
miraculously it doesn't touch ballistic
missiles on depressed trajectories it
doesn't touch low altitude aircraft it
doesn't touch cruise missiles it doesn't
touch motor boats in in harbors and
finally the Soviets have if SDI is
deployed a strong incentive towards
decoys and so-called penetration aides
and for all those reasons the response
to SDI available to the Soviets looks to
be cheaper and technologically ready er
than SDI itself the next question goes
to dr. Sagan and Gowen and that is that
science entails constant technological
advancement since SDI embodies the
pinnacle of American technology how can
you as scientists justify suppressing it
general Abramson said the work is not
science it's engineering and what I want
to do is to go back into a much smaller
program where science and imagination
holds sway and I wouldn't mind having a
general program for reducing the cost of
everything we do in the Defense
Department as well as in the government
so I think it's great if we can get this
promise of a $5,000 inertial guidance
system into production I think it would
be wonderful to use it in our strategic
offensive missiles as well as in the
defense but that's not an SDI thing
that's a technological thing science I'm
in favor of cheaper products I am in
I just don't think this ought to be done
under the mask of a long-term response
to the president's dream one man's dream
while delaying the near term
accomplishments in ballistic missile
defense that we could obtain if we did
not have a research and development only
program like Sagan one aspect of SDR
which I think has not been mentioned and
it's important to not lose sight is that
when you waive a trillion dollars at the
u.s. aerospace industry and scientists
and technologists you will produce what
one general officer described as a
feeding frenzy now what happens is that
any such goal whether it can be
accomplished or not whether it's
feasible or daft deflects a large
fraction of the available US scientific
and engineering talent away from other
tasks away from improving deterrence in
other ways away from conventional arms
work and especially away from the
civilian economy and in that way
SDI can work to erode national security
in the broad definition of Dwight
Eisenhower that I mentioned before just
one other thing I was asked but not at
the time that we had a chance to to
rebut by general Abramson what was the
connection he said between education and
SDI why do I put at the feet of SDIO all
of these underdeveloped nation qualities
of the United States that are getting
increasingly distressing the reason is
that all of those items I mentioned can
be addressed by money education can be
addressed by money and you say it's only
a small fraction of the Department of
Defense budget and an even smaller
fraction of the gross national product
yes that's true right now but if you
succeed in getting into a deployment
circumstance then the budget says
everybody acknowledged go way up so not
only will money
taken away from education but scientific
and engineering talent will be taken
away from education from the civilian
economy and so that's how all of those
items are connected with SDI general
Arizona mr. Pro will be a little bit
lenient on the time you have far I'm a
little disappointed I think I'd have to
say frankly because I came here
expecting I would hear a spirited
argument about SDI and what I'm what I
think I'm hearing is from the other side
is nitpicking about how much money we're
spending therefore SDI therefore having
a strategic research program they just
want to spend less money on it than we
do and if you believe Carl Sagan we're
going to raise or lower the infant
mortality rate if we just divert funds
from SDI into I don't know what program
the simple fact is that the SDI is
affordable and manageable particularly
if one looks at the enormous investment
that we now make in offensive forces and
can look forward to a future in which we
can reduce that emphasis on offensive
forces and use the consequent budget
reductions to finance SDI it's all very
well to talk about a trillion dollars in
some future but that's not the program
that we're operating no request has been
made for a trillion dollars unless the
research and development which is much
more manageable proportions indicates to
us that we have a financially sound and
technically competent program there
would not be any proposal to deploy much
less a proposal to deploy at a billion
dollars so I think we are being burdened
with responsibility for a program that
doesn't exist and yet when it comes down
to the crucial issue which is the
concept of whether it is wise to go
undefended I find that the other side
has conceded the point in both Garwin
and Sagan believe we ought to have a
defense they would just do it
differently from the way we would do it
in that differences there are quite a
few differences nice commented earlier
between what is theoretically possible
and what is operationally effective
clearly I agree in fact I'm in violent
agreement with both of you that we must
have a survivable kind of system
dr. Godwin raises one of his most
favorite of all kinds of issues space
mines and it is a serious problem it's
one that we do deal with we deal with
very very intelligently we spend a lot
of time and effort working on it he also
knows that much of it we are not allowed
to talk about however let me just deal
with one part of this issue so that you
understand the difference between the
way it is simplistically offered in the
theoretical sense and the reality of
this particular kind of countermeasure
and I only offer this as one example
often dick has explained that an
orbiting satellite if it's a if it's an
SDI satellite always goes in the same
path and therefore it's easy to put a
space mine up there and the image in
your mind that comes out of that is
perhaps something like a Persian Gulf
mind that they just kind of sit next to
a one of our satellites and there it
sits and we don't do anything in fact we
make our satellites so that they can
maneuver we give them hardening so that
they can handle nuclear weapons at least
up to a reasonable radius and those
areas are ones we're making progress in
DIC then says aha
but if space mine is simple and
therefore you can put more fuel on and
you can always stay with this
maneuvering satellite let me tell you
from my experience the last space
shuttle mission that I had was the first
time that we repaired a satellite in
space and equipment flew a very nearly
perfect kind of a rendezvous with the
solar max satellite and it took nearly
all of the fuel for maneuvering that the
Space Shuttle had as we did it secondly
that even if you can come into that
position and the rush
have automatic capability to do that
then the game is not even yet even still
because it is never perfect and once
again let me go to my experience as a
fighter pilot you've watched the
Thunderbirds of the Blue Angels and as
they fly it looks very smooth as they
stay in formation and move with this
system but I can tell you that the
people who are on the wing the wingmen
are sitting there working like mad
putting all kinds of control inputs into
this but the assertion that dr. Darwin
and the Union of Concerned Scientists
often make at the theoretical level is
far from the reality of the operational
situation thank you
next question goes to general Abramson
and mr. pearl and that is under what
circumstances would you accept a ban on
the deployment of SDI in return for deep
cuts in Soviet offensive weapons of
course one has to define the terms in
order to answer that question and I
don't know what is meant by deep cuts
but the proposals that are currently
being discussed in which offensive
nuclear weapons would be reduced to the
order of six thousand would still in my
judgment leave enormous scope for
horrendous damage and to go utterly
undefended in the face of nuclear forces
of that scale would I think be dangerous
and unwise so I would certainly not
agree to ban strategic defenses in
exchange for a reduction of that scale
the president at the Iceland summit
proposed to the Soviets that we would be
prepared to delay the deployment of
strategic defenses until after a period
of disarmament during which all the
offensive ballistic missiles on both
sides would be eliminated he made the
point which seemed to me logical and I
hope this is responsive to the question
that in the absence of strategic
offensive ballistic missiles no one
would have anything to fear from
the deployment of a strategic defense
since it would have nothing to shoot
down unless the unassign cheated the
Soviets flatly and categorically
rejected that proposal giving some
serious rise to the question why are the
Soviets so dead set against the United
States continuing a research and
development and testing program that
looks very much like their own and you
have 30 seconds of your time two minutes
to the opponent
I think the Soviets are so unhappy about
the u.s. SDI because they don't like to
sign an agreement with an insane partner
because they think that the SDI will not
work against the first Soviet first
strike and they asked what we want hit
for there is no real explanation fly let
me quote secretary pearl back from 1973
in a debate which we both participated
he says if the Minuteman is vulnerable
there's no need to fear that the Soviet
Union would actually launch such an
attack but the political consequences
would be dangerous how to get out of it
he said the best procedure would be to
defend strategic missile complexes with
ABMS the effect of such defense on
deterrence survival would be substantial
as an alternative however we should
press the Soviets to bring their
strategic forces down to the level of
comparable US forces now that's what
we're talking about now the 50%
reduction would be only a first step
toward much deeper cuts but those deeper
cuts will not happen if the residual
forces are disarmed in prospect by the
deployment of a Strategic Defense
I already quoted secretary Weinberger as
saying that a Soviet SDI would be the
worst strategic nightmare he could
imagine former Secretary of Defense
McNamara in the 1960s said if the
Soviets deploy this nationwide ABM
defense with 5,000 nuclear-armed
interceptors we will build 50,000
nuclear warheads to counter it if
necessary the step at a time defense is
precisely the recipe for
increasing the Soviet offensive force
and at every moment increasing the
potential destruction if nuclear war
comes I've seen I think we have to bear
very clearly in mind what would our
response be if the Soviets were
developing an SDI system of the sort
that we're talking about and we had to
face the possibility that what they had
in mind was a devastating first strike
against the United States with their SDI
system used to mop up the residual
retaliatory capability of the United
States that is precisely the
circumstance that they have to face with
SDI and they are quite properly worried
about that as we would all so therefore
there is the makings of a bargain here
each side for goes SDI and is at least
freed from that concern about a
devastating first strike we have before
us the historic opportunity we may not
occur again for massive reductions in
the strategic Arsenal's on both sides
and considering the absurdly large
number of such weapons it would be
foolish not to take advantage of that
opportunity next question to dr. godwinn
and dr. Sagan Richard Perle has stated
that there is evidence of an
overwhelming level of Soviet SDI
research do you agree that it's possible
to document the level of Soviet SDI type
research
I heard ambassador Warren Zimmerman in
the fall of 1985 to a group about the
size explained that the Soviet Union put
about 50% of its military budget into
strategic defense that sounded extreme
and somebody from the audience asked
whether he was sure and what was his
source he said after thinking yes he was
sure and his source was a recent CIA
study about which he couldn't say
anything more but I happened to have
with me the unclassified testimony of
Robert Gates and Larry Gershwin from
June 26 1985 and they said that the
Union spends about equal amounts on
strategic offense and strategic defense
together about 20% of their military
budgets so here this honest capable man
whom I knew personally was misleading
the audience
he said 50% of the military budget goes
to strategic defense the number in the
document he was quoting was 10% I have
no reason to doubt that the Soviets
spent 30 billion dollars a year in our
money on strategic defense but that
includes their vast air defense program
operating 10,000 radars 10,000
interceptors 3,000 fighter aircraft
their civil defense program with 3
billion dollars a year or so the
operation of their permitted system
around Moscow and yes some research on
SDI the answer to which is not a US
defense but our countermeasures program
which runs at about one part in 20 of
our current SDI program that's not a
countermeasures research program that's
a countermeasures deployment program so
I'm not troubled by the Soviet SDI they
have a very substantial effort in
numbers if you believe in numbers then
you really ought to worry about the
agriculture gap because we have 2% of
our people on the farm and they have 30%
now Sagan just like to underscore the
fuzzing that is often done by American
spokespersons between Soviet
anti-missile defense and Soviet
strategic defense which is largely
Soviet anti-aircraft defense which in
turn is due to the very great
preponderance of US strategic
intercontinental bombers over the
comparable not comparable much less
Soviet flies mr. pearl I hope I hope
those of you who are listening caught
the word yes very down deep in dick
Darwin's answer yes he said the Soviets
do have a Strategic Defense Initiative
it doesn't trouble him
but the fact that they have one
certainly ought to lead us to the
question of whether we can afford to be
without one now Carl Sagan wants to make
sure that nobody misunderstands the
statistics about Soviet defenses and in
order to make sure we don't he has
pointed out how much they spend on
defense against aircraft a variety of
other defenses decor would use the
figure thirty billion dollars it's fair
to ask isn't it what does this tell us
about the Soviet view of whether it is
right and proper and legitimate to have
a system of defences as you listen to
official Soviet spokesman who decried
the notion of defending one's forces and
indeed we've disturbed the other side in
this debate decry the notion of mounting
the defense look at what the Soviets are
doing in every area in which they have
been capable of mounting the defense
they have done so defense against our
bombers defenses to the degree they can
against our submarines a variety of
measures intended to assure that their
strategic deterrent could survive attack
and perhaps to do more than that we
ought to be doing precisely the same
thing in the most effective way we can
providing for defenses and on the other
side they would have us do it entirely
by relying on offensive forces and only
those defenses other than SDI I think
the only conclusion you can come to is
it on the other side they just don't
like the SDI program that concludes the
period for questions and now we're going
to go to concluding statements each
participant will be allowed three
minutes for a concluding statement and
we will begin with dr. Colin
secretary pearl is right I don't like
the SDI program it was born in fantasy
and carried out like the admirers of the
Emperor who had new codes now we don't
actually have to be naked to nuclear
weapons we can wear a small amount of
codes but what is bad is to believe that
you are fully covered when you are not I
would like to take a little of my
closing time to point out that the
leader of the SDI program has here given
a couple of comments which are not
actually attributable to me he says I
want to put nuclear weapons in the
ground and blow them up in the northern
territories no not unless you believe
the northern term territories a one mile
north of each silo where we would have a
small nuclear explosion which would
never go off because there would never
be an attack if there is an effective
defense same argument as the SDI makes
except that this would really be an
effective countable defense he points
out that the shuttle has great
difficulty maneuvering to achieve a
position with respect to a satellite I'm
not proposing a manned a reusable space
mine that's the trouble with the shuttle
it carries a very small almost vanishing
percentage of its mass into orbit as
maneuvering fuel a space mine can carry
50% or 70% as maneuvering fuel it has no
other mission I really do believe that
the SDI has to look at the threat as it
will come if that's the best kind of
space mine man maneuvering space mine
which cost a billion dollars and carry
the percent or two of maneuvering fuel
they don't understand the space mine
threats the other two counters to the
SDI and the reason why it will not be
found to be adequately cheap and
survivable are the fast burn booster the
Soviets built missiles as did we
liquid-fueled if they go to solid fuel
missiles which they already have the
number of satellites which can
participate
fate in the attack on the missiles in
boost phase will drop from something
like 13 percent to 1 or 2 percent with
the missiles that the Soviets have now
with the fast burn boosters that the
fletcher committee considered not a
single one of the defensive satellites
could destroy a Soviet missile in boost
phase the other problem three problems
are space mines overt space mines fast
burn boosters and the third is nuclear
armed and he fat like weapons which the
Soviets already have they're called
galosh interceptors they are deployed
around Moscow they could make as many of
them as they like they would come up
against the defense of satellites at the
time of a first like if you believe
there would be one anyhow and they would
destroy them they would carry decoys so
that they could not be injured by the
small rockets which are the defending
satellites only means for the next 10 or
20 years to destroy boosters in fact it
is unlikely that these warheads would
even be seen by the defensive satellites
so we really have to look at this we
shouldn't look at it only in controversy
like this we ought to get together and
discuss these matters it would help if
the SDI would read my papers thank
[Applause]
[Music]
now for his concluding statement Richard
Perle I'll say I'm sorry to general
Abramson excuse me I think the important
thing about the entire debate is number
one we both believe in some defenses
some investment here that's critical
there is a complete difference about
what it should be what the investment
really and truly should be in terminal
defenses or something that can be much
more effective layered defenses there's
a great deal of difference between the
assessment of progress and perhaps most
importantly about where we can
potentially go the difference is that
these are criticisms which are aimed at
the potential of the future where we
have thousands and thousands of people
across the country who are out there
making the changes and making the future
happen so that when a deployment happens
it will indeed meet the criteria that
the president outlined those criteria
are very clear
we haven't projected any kind of a
difference from those criteria those are
first of all that it be militarily
effective second that'd be survivable
thirdly that it in fact produce arms
race stability by making it less
expensive to build one of these systems
than it is to counter it by building
more of the same now I'd like for you to
imagine just a little bit dr. Sagan
introduced an imaginative picture here
think of what an ss-18 truly is and
ss-18 about nine stories high as a huge
machine and that it has it weighs nearly
half a million pounds now just the raw
material and the cost in that particular
system is immense we are working now for
the space-based interceptors and not
exclusively only on space-based
interceptors but on those systems for
something that will be about three feet
high and that will weigh on the order of
150 to 170
my pounds now will that be
cost-effective at the margin there is no
question just from the from the overall
kind of technology and the differences
in what we can produce that we're
working in an area where we have an
advantage we will not bring forward a
proposal to deploy until it makes sense
until it meets those criteria but I can
assure you it's happening very very
quickly regarding dr. Carlin's point we
are working more seriously on each of
those sort of those countermeasures than
he understands he has had access to many
of the classified areas of the program
and I have specifically authorized him
to go into some of those areas and I
just leave you with one last challenge
dick for some of your systems that you
think are so effective I would ask for
you to bring that proposal and
operationally effective proposal to me a
practical proposal that we can implement
because that's what we're working on not
the theoretical counter countermeasures
but the real countermeasures that can be
effective and for his concluding
statement dr. Carl Sagan last week there
was a Harris Poll of the American people
concerning the negotiations on reducing
the budget deficit which may or may not
be concluded this week 82% of the
American people said that they did not
want social programs cut fifty-eight
percent believed that significant
defense cuts are essential for deficit
productions these are very large
majorities considering the enormous
barrage of argument from the Department
of Defense the White House and their
supporters on the need for a military
buildup to Chilean dollars has been
spent on the military since they've been
in office I think it is remarkable to
see the independent voice of the
American people on this issue it is true
that the smaller the scale that SDI is
imagined the cheaper it will be and
therefore the more politically
accessible it will be if general
Abramson and mr. Perot are saying that
full of population defense is only one
of the possibilities of of SDI fine it
is a possibility which is not very
likely not very cost-effective and
indeed very dangerous if the objective
is to find some other way of enhancing
deterrence if the objective is some
other way to shoot down an errant
missile let us find out how to do that
without being burdened by the
president's vision of an overall
population of Defense Star Wars is a
highly porous system which cannot
protect civilian population of the
United States even without Soviet
countermeasures there are a wide range
of Soviet countermeasures available to
them the system can be overwhelmed it
can be under flown overwhelmed by adding
more warheads under flown by delivering
nuclear weapons by ways other than how
the arc and ballistic missile
trajectories it can be outfoxed it is an
inefficient way to enhance deterrence it
is ruinously expensive it is likely to
increase not decrease the likelihood of
the or except for all of that it's a
terrific idea
I would like to see this administration
devote some small fraction of the media
time and bureaucratic attention to
explaining why it's important to reduce
the strategic Arsenal's in a massive
bilateral intrusively inspected missile
reduction and to be responsive to the
growth test build-up of nuclear weapons
since 1945 to the present time something
which future generations if there are
any will regard with the same abhorrence
that we regard the institutions of human
sacrifice or chattel slavery in terms of
simple planetary hygiene it is essential
that we reduce those Arsenal's at least
at first to a tiny fraction of their
present numbers and to free the human
species from this specter of massive
destruction thank you
[Music]
and now in conclusion his final
statement Richard Perle I hope Carl
Sagan that perhaps when he visits here
in December you will have an opportunity
to make that impassioned appeal to mr.
Gorbachev because we have had on the
table from the from the earliest days of
the administration proposals to reduce
radically the strategic Arsenal's of
both sides I find a little curious the
way this debate has taken shape we are
general Abramson la Abramson and I on
one side respectively a longtime public
official and a professional soldier and
on the other side we have two scientists
I was brought up to believe that science
has a method and that method is to
identify a hypothesis to do research and
experimentation and carefully collect
data and ultimately render some judgment
about the validity of that hypothesis
hypothesis before us today is whether
SPI
will prove to be in the national
interest and us non scientists on this
side of the same table have said let's
collect the evidence let's do the
research let's record the results
carefully and then following the
scientific method let's make a decision
about whether we have accomplished a
program that is affordable and that is
in our national interest that's not a
question that we can answer today and I
find astonishing the certitude on the
other side of the table first that SDI
won't work and second that there are a
dozen different ways to overcome it if
it does work they also seem to be quite
certain about what the Soviets will do
and yet if the Soviets take seriously
their judgment about the effectiveness
of the program Carl Sagan just said you
can understand under fly it out Fox it
they needn't respond at all except by
under swimming and under flying and out
Fox they don't have to build initial
additional weapons
let me conclude by trying for a moment
to put this in some historical context
this debate is not unlike a debate that
took place in the 1940s after World War
two when Harry Truman was president of
the United States and some of you will
recall a debate in those days over
whether the United States ought to
proceed to develop the hydrogen bomb it
wasn't carried out in public it was
carried out in fact in great secrecy and
the scientific community pretty much
divided 90% against proceeding and 10%
for and the 90% were led you will recall
by Robert Oppenheimer and a small band
10% or so led by Edward Teller argued
that we should proceed to develop the
h-bomb the argument of the 90% was that
if we proceeded to develop hydrogen
weapons the Soviets would do the same
and there would be instability and great
danger the argument of the minority was
that it was imprudent not to proceed we
now know that while that debate was
taking place while Oppenheimer and
teller were making their respective
arguments a young Soviet physicist by
the name of Andrei Sakharov had already
been assigned by Joseph Stalin the task
of developing the Soviet hydrogen bomb
and had Harry Truman who wanted to see
the facts as they emerged from the
research and Harry Truman decided with
Robert Oppenheimer and not with Edward
Teller the Soviet Union would have
emerged in the late 1940s or early 1950s
with a monopoly of thermonuclear weapons
and I leave it to you to conclude how
the face of the globe how the values
that Carl Sagan and Dick Irwin and
general Abramson and I all share might
have been altered I hope we don't make
the mistake that Harry Truman refused to
make and believe
that we can stop history and the other
side just by wishing things were
different
I would like to thank all of the
panelists for joining us here today I
believe that we've had an excellent
debate exchange of ideas and I want to
thank our speakers and I want to thank
all of you who are here for your
participation in this important debate
the cañon caucus room has never been as
filled as it is today and I think it's a
reflection of the importance of the
issue which were debating that it was
able to draw this kind of attention
across Washington and in fact people
from across the country who came in here
today for this debate I'd like to thank
the staff of space watch who put
together this forum here today
[Applause]
they they consist of Eric first Cynthia
Kelly
Patrick Tracy Kathryn McGraw Arthur
Klein and Dan child's and I think they
did an absolutely splendid job in
organizing a debate of this magnitude
and I'd also like to use this
opportunity to offer some closing
observations on the future of the Star
Wars proposal I believe that the year
ahead of us is going to be a year of
reckoning for the Strategic Defense
Initiative program between now and
December of 1988 the president the
Congress and the American people have
some important decisions to make about
Star Wars and national security
decisions which ultimately should be
based on a determination of whether or
not style was is in the national
interest the president has to decide
whether he is willing to accept some
limits on Star Wars in return for deep
cuts in US and Soviet strategic nuclear
arms Congress has to decide what level
of funding it wishes to provide for
style was and whether to limit style was
testing in order to ensure continued
adherence to the traditional
interpretation of the ABM Treaty the
American people have to decide on who
will be our next president and whether
they want an administration committed to
Star Wars testing and deployment our one
committed to preservation of the ABM
Treaty and willing to discuss limits on
the exotic technologies of Star Wars how
these decisions will come out is
anybody's guess but I think that in
today's discussion we have had a chance
to look at some of the questions that
must be considered before our country
commits itself to proceeding with Star
Wars testing and development questions
like will style waz work or Kenneth al
Fox overwhelm or be all flown will it
make our cities in population safer or
will it only defend on missile silos and
military command centers how much will
it cost and can it meet the NIT search
area of cost effectiveness at the margin
well it uh sure in a new strategic
relationship based on defenses or will
it destroy
prospects for arms control and touch off
a strategic offensive and defensive arms
race underlying these questions is the
more fundamental one should we put our
faith in technological solutions to our
problems or should we seek political
solutions negotiated solutions Congress
has decided this year to limit style was
funding to no more than three point nine
billion dollars and to prohibit any
testing outside the traditional
interpretation of the ABM Treaty that
gives enough time for our next president
to make the decision on whether or not
to go ahead with style was one of the
great things about our system of
government is that the people decide who
they want to have serve as their leaders
and what direction they want the country
to move towards the final decision on
who our next president will be is in the
hands of the people who are in this room
the people who are watching this
broadcast in millions of others across
this country for they will be choosing a
new administration to begin serving in
January of 1989 you and the people like
you will determine who will sit in the
Oval Office and who will sit across from
the negotiating table from general
secretary Gorbachev in making that
decision I would hope that very serious
consideration will be given to the issue
that we have discussed today whether
style was is in the national interest if
you want to continue to be a prized of
stock of space watches program of
debates throughout the coming year on
this and other issues please contact our
staff immediately after this proceeding
and we were more than willing to put you
on our mailing list if you have any
ideas in terms of how we can frame
debates for public discussion please
come forward with those ideas as well we
need the input of all sides if we are in
fact going to be able to frame this
debate in a way in which the election of
1988 or reflect reflects the important
the informed citizenry that we really
to have so once again I want to thank
panelists dr. gawa and dr. Sagan general
Abramson and Richard Perle I think they
all did an excellent job and we thank
all of you feel